premier ministre couillard on l'a vu
promet que le ou les auteurs de cette
menace seront pourchassés et frédéric ce
ne sera pas une tâche très facile
non parce qu'on est loin du temps où
lorsque des petits plaisantins ou des
personnes mal intentionnées proféré des
menaces via téléphone c'est assez facile
alors de remonter à la source
on appelait la compagnie de téléphone
cellulaire ou bien la ligne terrestre et
en obtenait on arrive à en fait à
remonter à la source avec interne est un
peu plus compliquée en fait quand on
pense par exemple si vous m'envoyez ce
soir un courriel électronique donc moi
je vais voir évidemment votre adresse en
bas du message mais aussi je vais avoir
accès à votre adresse ip alors ça c'est
vraiment la signature numérique unique
qui est quasiment indélébile de
l'ordinateur que vous avez utilisé alors
comment faire pour envoyer un courriel
de façon totalement anonyme en fait il
existe des dizaines de sites internet
qui vous offre cette possibilité en fait
ils vont utiliser des serveurs qui vont
permettre de retransmettre votre message
de façon complètement anonyme donc sans
mention de votre nom sans mention
également de la fameuse adresse ip alors
il y en a pleins pleins plats qui sont
utilisés et celui qui a été utilisé en
fait par la personne qui a envoyé la
menace ce matin c'est celui ci qui a
l'air un peu d'un site des années 80
avec une interface très minimaliste et
c'est un site qui avait déjà utilisé
pour envoyer un courriel de menaces en
2003 vis-à-vis de la ville de chicago
mais alors là c'est existe des moyens de
retracer malgré tout l'origine d'un
courrier à la nanny mais c'est possible
si jamais la police parvient à
identifier le fournisseur d'accès
internet par exemple comme bell ou
vidéotron qui auraient utilisé mais avec
par le biais d'un mandat il serait
capable de demander à l'entreprise de
lever l'identité de la personne qui a
envoyé ce fameux message sauf que si la
personne a envoyé à partir d'un
ordinateur public comme dans une
bibliothèque par exemple ou aurait
utilisé la par exemple l'accès internet
sans fil dans un café internet
là ça devient quasiment impossible de
retrouver la source donc c'est pas
impossible mais ça va être vraiment très
très difficile de retracer cette
personne n'a quoi alors peut-être une
option ce serait de demander à des
familles pirates informatiques comme
anonymous par exemple qui pourrait peut
travailler et aller rechercher peut-être
ces informations-là mai
c'est assez rare de voir une
collaboration entre les pirates
informatiques et les opérations
policières en général c'est vrai merci
beaucoup aux frais que vous en plus